I started losing my vision...
...around the same time that I started teaching myself how to cook.
Every time my vision would decrease,...
...I would have to teach myself again how do I use the stove or how do I use a knife.
Just trying to get better every day with every recipe I made.
I'm best known for winning a cooking competition on television.
I also wrote a cookbook that made it onto the best seller list.
Now, I'm considered an insider in the industry.
As someone who's visually impaired, measuring liquids has been a challenge.
I use voice-activated technology a lot in the kitchen,
It's just much easier to speak to a device whether it's measurements,...
...getting equipment to turn on or off.
Cooking is a very central process.
Because I don't have the sense of sight, when I taste something,...
...I really break it down in my head.
I picture exactly how I want the dish to look.
I have the memory of what colors looked like,...
...so I know what white, what orange, what green look like,
So, I imagine first, I think, the art on a dish.
This is when I feel the most Zen.
Pho is a dish that even though it's that simple, it's hard to execute.
Although each time I make it, it gets better and better,...
...it has yet to still capture the memory of my mom's.
Whether it's trying to get through challenges to win a cooking competition,...
...to opening a restaurant,...
...to just trying to replicate my mom's beef noodle soup.
You just have to try over and over until you succeed.